I want to take good morning my brother
good lorry job this is Lu su he makes
YouTube videos mostly in Spanish but
also in English system in Maxim Spanish
catalyst iced tea Akiko hug a Punto de
Rivoli Chalmers random video in Montana
to reality and so common so go look no
oh it's an itchy yeah yeah it's an
expression that we have it's only in
Spain like giving people Latin America
is like what well you see it about my
kids are gonna make fun of me my kids
can be so American dad you know that
it's not like that it's like we're like
that you said something it sounds like
penis really and you don't know you make
videos in the certain language and you
switch it's like you lose levels in a
game you know like do you still your
Pokemon go levels in your packet wow we
have great videos the people will enjoy
and you stuff like this well I don't
even know how to explain explain it in
Spanish seto como que no puedo esperar
me alejandro de nieve en lo que está
siendo pero no puedo esperar me
correctamente
in English a polymer of en español Barea
Hamas in English Yona see the wall are
we in for a sign for every builder gives
us suggestions for things to do I'm
gonna open our query or have another six
mountain Mountain coffee
materials in essence yeah she's like
lumberjack Patrick wants us to stare at
each other intensely
verifying blink there yeah I know and
what it is to like I don't hear it from
Holland talking Spanish Bell honks Jane
tada Khachaturian Cara pekka's carpetas
video loss las olas carpetas muy bien
por que hace bien es todo organized Oddo
convey esta la biblioteca la biblioteca
de esta ahi Camino de Albertsons ah yeah
yeah you ain't bothered they said you
were is not David once you teach me
Spanish save this where could I work
Lucilla's fantastical subscrive it as to
canal cool you just colored water
subscribe to my channel not a lot has to
do tongue twisters do you know any
English tongue twisters no nothing
English I know in Spanish so it's that
one what about fat tigers yeah tres
trista strigas frog aha Raghavan three
go in Antigua entries three states trust
Oregon ha ha Gabon three ghosts rest
Reese's tigress missile super America
new duet wrist wrist st Estragon trio
entry Allen tres Vista stressed Oh
Rodrigo dressed respectively high slip
this no you don't understand how long it
takes for someone from outside to learn
the difference between sheet in other
words start going on the beach and other
one thing else yeah I flip the
ice-laden on this little I see
Sylvia says both come to Pokemon
he's got the Pokemon Patrick says make a
tutorial about how to be cool like you
both first of all we have different
kinds of cool like Hank is cool like you
know let's get not at all
it matters when intellectual kind of
cool I'm cool you know the other way
somebody said that we should kiss but
I'm not going to kiss you because you're
sick since Montana do this to you I'm
kind of definitely shut the last bullet
it's so cool
I was walking now it's like 36 well yeah
I saw a server in the river yesterday we
have surfing criticisms of ice yeah
there's IO in the road in the river
you guys have Grizzlies here we don't
mountain town well known that in the
grocery story I say well no but we get
black bears in town oh yeah they're an e
Black Bears aren't they're not babies
yeah there's beets
also relaxing cup okay I got you all get
into yourself
Jenna was out I let see this for the
first day right here on the moment that
your girlfriend takes is you with
something like that it's just well now
you really do have to go alright thanks
if I judge on buying a few auger dollars
preferably Greg is leather jackets with
you
lumberjack